marianne me plaît j'aime la diversité
j'adore c'est donc maison c'est dans mon
âme
[Musique]
ylang québécoise
j'adore québec parce que de vivre en
français émeraude
quand je sors de ma maison pour aller
prendre un café
je m'attends pas d'être servis en
anglais je parle en français puis ça
pour moi je trouve que c'est la réalité
typique de la plupart de montréal est
montréalaise ici alors ça va oui merci
je prends mon café pour apporter ce
taper tout la dream aunis né à montréal
a vécu sa jeunesse en grèce et elle est
revenue au canada à l'âge adulte elle a
choisi montréal pour sa diversité et
elle apprécie les effets de la loi sur
tous les anglophones que je connais sont
bilingues trous les allophones que je
connais sont presque tous trilingue puis
d'abord pour moi c'est vraiment un
secret story journalistes en milieu
anglophone elle juge la loi 96 trouve
sévère en particulier pour les
autochtones et les nouveaux arrivants de
traiter les gens comme une menace comme
les migrants sont une menace pour la
langue française ça empêche les ans les
gens de se sentir comme chez nous deux
c'est d'avoir cette sentiment
d'appartenance j'ai appris le français
parce que pour moi c'était c'est une
affaire d'amour je voulais comme
vraiment sain richesse pour moi
des vacances mais aussi un autre
maniaque du melting-pot montréalais
[Musique]
ardent défenseur de sa ville toujours
prêt à faire découvrir une musique
francophone ses amis quand on dit qu'on
est des enfants de sentein c'est qu'on
en connaît l'importance de la langue
française et on sait que ces intégrales
pour le futur du québec de perdre et
français d'avoir le lorrain déçu en
français la culture enfoncé le montréal
de mes paroles entamant où c'était pas
le bouffeur de ses larmes et sigmund
freud et tu n'allais pas as dû papineau
c'est à montréal que je connais
pour lui les relations entre glow phone
et francophones ont toujours été facile
à montréal mais il craint que ce ne soit
en train de changer
de moto speak french quand c'est arrivé
ça beaucoup d'anglophones à lyon non ça
va ouvrir un gros problème pour nous ça
il n'est pas représentatif de 2 nous pas
du tout et puis la loi 96 a été adopté
le projet de loi numéro 96 et tu as
donné
c'est du populisme c'est du hac ne
nationalisent et c'est pas un bon bloc
pour le québec c'est pas le mouvement de
souverainisme que je souviens de ma
jeunesse
les études de l'office québécois de la
langue française confirme régulièrement
le déclin du français en particulier
dans le monde du travail surtout à
montréal une affirmation que réfute la
majorité des anglo-québécois soit
environ un million de personnes
car angers voit la vitalité de français
la culture francophone la littérature
québécoise que j'aime autant j'ai un peu
la misère de dire que la france est
vraiment en danger et si tu veux que
c'est un déclin des desjardins fait plus
le bébé mais si c'est un déclin de la
langue française je ne vois pas ça du
tout moi de ma part je pense pas qu'elle
est menacée mais c'est mon expérience
personne
n'importe où que je vais je parle
français que ça soit à montréal ou au
québec moi c'est ça la langue dans
lequel je vis ma vie depuis les dix
dernières années je dirais de plus
amples
anna francis meier a 28 ans et vient
d'une famille anglophone elle a étudié
en anglais c'est la musique et son
conjoint francophones qui l'ont amené à
franchir tout naturellement la barrière
linguistique c'est comme pas un enjeu
pour les gens de mon âge j'ai
l'impression que le français il vraiment
en bonne santé que les gens sont fiers
de la parler
[Musique]
bonjour segré
alors bien le français supposément en
danger mais français n'est pas en danger
les gens ont réagi à la comparaison de
monsieur legault avec la louisiane la
grande majorité des québécois et
immigrants sont obligés de fréquenter
l'école française donc ça ne peut pas
disparaître cet avocat de grand
défenseur des droits et libertés a été
dans le passé un pourfendeur de la loi
101 avant de se raviser dans les années
1990 aujourd'hui il s'insurge contre la
loi 96 qui juge bien pire parce que
discriminatoires dans son ensemble on va
dire à quelqu'un par exemple qui est
malade dans un hôpital monsieur est ce
que vous avez votre carte de
d'anglophones de souche pour que je
puisse vous traitez à l'anglais mais
quelle absurdité c'est pas
l'indépendantisme qui me dérange je vais
voter pour le parti indépendantiste
ce qui me dérange c'est le nationalisme
ethnique c'est l'identité c'est la
crainte
que le nationalisme ethnique est en
train d'être revenir au pouvoir au
québec on a boat media days and should
be dans le camp francophone
ce week end comprenant
caractère car
c'était le premier discours public du
premier ministre bouchard après l'échec
référendaire de 1995
un discours qui visait à rassurer la
communauté anglophone sur son rôle et sa
place au québec
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce genre d'attention que semblent
réclamer aujourd'hui une bonne part des
anglophones et des allophones de la part
du gouvernement ça se peut pas faire
dans le non sens ça doit être un débat
incluant nous s'il vous plaît on est
plus que sur un côté que tu penses je ne
dis pas que on n'a pas besoin de des
lois je comprends leurs raisons pour les
lois dans sa tête il faut qu on remanie
qu'on se réajuste un peu face à ceux des
bosses et on veut y aller dans une
culture de nos animaux cités et
d'entraidé peut-être finalement car
c'est là la rupture entre les deux
solitudes